le premier combat benjamin castaldi à
mon badge i oui bon produit à chamakh
castaldi lui qu' aucune finesse c'est
pour lui et sa boule la suite opposé
directement votre mamie aulas quel beau
combat
izard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
élie vinet version unique 4 e gilbert
est ce qu'on est compromise attend donc
maintenant à castanet ne gagnera pas
loyal ou adaptations ou manip stop stop
elle est pas mal ça moi je veux une
valse à la ola la mairie muni d'un
caddie deux heures de maquillage pour r
quel 2h04 cudi qui va être opposé à
jeter les bouteilles justice istanbul
kelly qui est opposé à maxime gainey non
combat mais il va être c'est beau ça
tranquille à gerber duke sensationnel
que gilles verdez est qualifiée
compliments vont glisser sur 48 heures
moto je tiens le truc attention
attention avec des talons bien dedans
bien dedans les chaînons savez vous à
nous dire non on a bientôt dans les
chais et demi attention 3 2
[Musique]
c'est kenny est tué merci merci merci
attention troisième cas je suis fou de
ce jeu du foot une maxime galy qui est
opposé un choc dans le pays
on peut pas en dire aux maquilleuses et
gérad d'une valise à la main sur ça
s'est équilibré
est ce que tu veux que ce soit hier à
dubaï et attention attention les chefs à
l'arraché natation oui c'est vrai s'il
vous plaît voilà 3 2 géraldine maxime ça
va pas attendez on le retrouvait bien
attention remettez bien attention c'est
robin giral et mettez vous bien votre
quête de dents j'adorais elle a dit john
et là commence en amont quand une
mondialisation et voie puisque enfin 2
gera des moyens et qualifiez vous savez
j'adore que d'autres la bizarre débat
oui il va bien et maxi attention dernier
quart de finale et il y en aura deux
petits jours ou pas il reste qui s'il
vous plaît j'irai caroline vous avez
joué coupé y aller il reste mathieu
pierre toi et moi à isabelle et jean
michel danesin dit stop
ça c'est ma boule tu déjà épuisés pour
tordre à la moustache la personne a déjà
gagné un toit mes yeux mais le milieu a
lieu matthieu boone jouera doucement
attention je vois pas très attention à
tiéné ses droits des êtres place en 2001
ya une place en demi finale attention
c'est parti
il faut mettre un prix public alésien
nom à l'enceinte de la techno vous
mettez la tête là dessus voilà attention
au square 2
wen
[Applaudissements]
la première demi finale oppose donc on
as qu on pas voir les qualifier s'il
vous plaît on admire a dit mme maillet
s'il vous plaît comme ça depuis janvier
77 pas opposé gilbert bête mais à kelly
b dom et mes côtés tu étais fan du
droitier lire khelifa s'agit alors merci
attention à toi tu en dises ait attendu
3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
je vais rebelles
attention attention attention attention
la deuxième demi finale
géraldine maillet face à isabelle morini
bosc à venir le choc bonne élève
attention les chéris attention hein
attend ces trois pays située à toi
est-ce que vous êtes prêts ouais mais
les mettez vous bien
allez c'est pas bon il faut se mettre à
la voyons pas isabelle laisser tomber ça
c'est pas grave ma chérie mettez-vous
comme ça et mettez bien votre manque
d'attention est ce que vous êtes prêts
ouais mais tu es bien votre moto et
géraldine sinon attention 3,2 à taper
on va prendre quelqu'un au téléphone
allô allô cayla alors oui bien sûr ma
chérie comment tu t'appelles c'est la
main en s'en tient aux faits mais chéri
comment tu t'appelles
oui lui si ça va lui si ça va ma chérie
très bien ma chérie tu nous appelles de
paris petite ceinture merci tu es tu
fais dans la vie lucide je cherche du
travail non quoi ma chérie la vente
d'alcool dans la vente alors ma chérie
dans un instant on va jouer avec
géraldine maillet gilles verdez pour la
finale il ya un séjour au ski a gagné
magnifique tu vas parier sur qui tu as
une verdez est forfait c'est beaucoup
trop curieux merci attention à ce que
vous êtes président
oui oui vous êtes prêts attention je
vous rappelle vous allez devoir appuyer
sur le bouton
celui qui arrive à mettre la mousse à
raser sur le visage de l'autre gagnera
il à l'uci au téléphone qui joue pour un
voyage au ski et vous gagnerez également
en voyage au ski si vous gagnez à la
parier sur gilles verdez c'est à
chamonix
regardez comme c'est beau c'est
magnifique j'ai été faire cette photo
hier on coucher de soleil
enfin les chéris attention sinon c'est
lourd qui gagnera le cadeau si c'est
géraldine maillet qui est ce que vous
êtes prêts oui trois dit gg de là on le
fera juste après non
[Applaudissements]
après trois mois
mais si tu penses qui m'a tuer
non non c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
merci
bravo web a franchement et et gilles
garde s il est très fort parce qu'il est
très laid triche à la fin notre voix